welcome back to the morning toast i'm so
excited because someone i love someone i
admire and someone who i've been
following forever is finally on the show
miss portia thank you so much for being
here thank you for having me i just want
i have so much to ask you but i just
want to tell you first and foremost like
i come on here week after week daily day
after day and i defend you like i am
such a stan and i just love you and i
want to thank you my first question
actually is i really want to know how
your back is my back why was i well it
must be in deep deep pain from putting
the franchise on it for so many years
how is it doing how are you doing
it's healing yeah i mean it's a lot it
was for a long time oh well well thank
you i really appreciate that especially
you know after 10 years after being in
i'm glad you feel like i hail my own
thank you definitely did and the show
will not be the same without you i want
to hear that too yeah you always said
like leave a job and then it's like
how's that girl
thank you miss me miss me please miss me
this is a crazy time for you it's like a
transitional period obviously you're off
real housewives of atlanta and i think a
lot of people were really surprised by
that yeah but then the announcement that
you got your own show which is obviously
like the dream yes was not surprising to
anyone oh it wasn't i watched it last
night i loved it i thought it was great
i think you're just such a natural and i
love your family like i really love your
relationship with your sister i host my
show with my sister it's just the best
and i think i l what i really loved
about the show was like you really
brought your whole family in but i think
a natural question is like do you ever
want to kill them like you really spend
so much time with them i do too people
ask me that all the time well are they
family if you don't that's true that's
true i think that's what makes you
family you want to kill them and you
don't yeah like you just love them
forever and i think that
you know love the way we love each other
and if you're honest with each other
then you're going to have some of those
crazy moments yeah that's just how it
works are they super comfortable filming
the show they like it um they weren't at
first really yeah i i actually told andy
last night that we had filmed a little
luncheon or i think it was at dinner i
can't remember and um you know i know my
family all right and i know that's why
we got the show i was like okay
everybody's got all these personalities
but in this particular get-together
everybody was like for tv like
yeah and i told them afterwards i called
them individually i was like listen you
know this is my world but you're now in
it yeah and the way i want this show to
be is raw and authentic so whatever
you're thinking whatever you're feeling
this is our reality as a family so you
feel safe to be yourself in front of
these cameras and i don't know why i did
that because the rest of the show was
lit i was like um
they're not holding back at all they're
not they're not but that's that's family
and that's the beauty of it you know
what i'm saying is that it can get a
little bit crazy but the goal at the end
of the day is love and to be blended
properly of course and i think that like
that was the takeaway for me i thought
the show was so great i loved the family
aspect i love this like new season of
your life like you're just like in the
best place probably ever that you've
been like yeah and i think we'll talk
about a lot about your book but that's
kind of the culmination of this whole
thing it's like finally being able to
tell your story yes you're now not on an
ensemble show it's your show and you
really feel do you feel like this is
now a time we know you for a long time
you've been on tv but you feel like now
you can really get to know the audience
on like a deeper level thank you for
mentioning my book so this is actually
such a beautiful moment that i feel like
was supposed to happen like this yeah at
this moment my book being released the
pursuit of porsha that is filled with my
family because they make you who you are
i don't care what you say i agree if
you're as close with your family as i am
they have been my strength through so
many different things and it's all in
the book and now you get to meet them on
the show that's true it's like it's
crazy it's like
it it is very revealing a a totally
different side of me that i know fans
haven't seen on housewives because you
get to see my family but you don't get
to see it like this no and let's talk
about the book so the book just came out
it's called the pursuit of porsha i have
a lot of questions the first question is
you get really kind of like deep in the
book yeah um you talk about eating
disorders spousal rape um
i'm curious if you were hesitant at all
to put some of those darker things in
because it can be really scary to open
up about you're always fun and you're
always like when it gets kind of heavy
it's a lot to open up to people like
that
so
me being
celebrity you know
one of the things that comes with that
is i think that different people in the
spotlight they check things off the list
so boom you're on tv or famous get a
perfume
you know sell something and do a book so
for me
when it came to doing a book i did not
want to do one because i knew that when
i did it it had to be completely honest
yeah so it took me some time to get to
the place to where it was i wanted to
share these different things
um but i knew it had to be purposeful so
right around the pandemic you know
everybody's doing self-reflection and
you just kind of take an account of your
life and what's important to you and
where you've been and where you have
gotten to
and i just felt so blessed to be
free at this moment that i wanted to
share my testimony and so when it came
to writing the book it was really
difficult because i knew in order to do
that i had to revisit a lot of dark
moments that i have never ever even
spoke about
too out loud actually and a lot some of
those things in the book i hadn't even
talked to my mom about oh and did you
speak to her before you release the book
so when i
when i was beginning to write the book i
had to talk with my mom and let her know
i touched on some of the things i wanted
to talk about to just i don't know get
her approval to be that open i mean i've
been on tv for 10 years
but of course i'm 40 years old and so
i've had a lot of life that i lived
prior to the camera and even when the
cameras were off and i was still on the
show there's a lot that happened yeah
that wasn't known so but she told me you
know at the end of the day i know you're
doing it because you want to help
inspire someone else through their tough
times so she said feel free to do it and
so i was open so what i thought was
interesting is you have a note from the
author before the book starts it says to
protect the privacy of my loved ones and
other people whom i've met and would
rather forget some names have been
changed others have been erased which i
thought was really powerful and i've
seen people put you know notes like that
at the beginning of their book i just
thought the way you worded it was really
well done and i'm curious if you've
heard from anyone that you wrote about
in the book that either in a positive
way or a negative way if they've reached
out to you
so first of all in the book there are
people who i don't name right and then
there's people who i mention and of
course i'd rather forget them but i also
did name a couple people in the book you
know and
um it was all about
me telling my side and when you read the
book because it starts from childhood
and you are really truly on a journey in
the book to really see the patterns in
my life and how i made some bad choices
fell in some bad situations business
relationship
i wanted to say is i wanted to stay as
close
to being honest as i could
um and legally some names weren't in
there um and then some were in there and
we don't know what may happen legally
but i just felt that i needed to do that
in order for the book to be completely
about me now being powerful feeling
powerful
and um feeling like i'm walking in my
purpose you know what i thought was
really interesting on your um episode
last night was what an emphasis you put
on social media and how it can get
really bother you
um and how like the people's reactions
to your relationship or just any part of
your life like it does eat away at you
you're a human being and i'm curious if
you've had any struggles with that with
the book because you're opening up so
much in the book and does it
does it concern you at all thinking what
your fans might think
um
here's the thing i am so excited for
people to actually read the book so at
this moment you're getting snippets
of headlines from the book i'm most
excited people to read it in its
entirety so you can get the full story
and it'll be and it'll you can
understand it a little bit better so in
this moment where it's kind of like just
lines out there it's a little like ah
you could be it could be misunderstood
the problem the book is for me to be
understood got it so that you can get
the point of the book so i think um
within doing this tour i i'm going to
really be more comfortable
with talking to certain things in the
book speaking of different things you're
at barnes and noble today right so
everyone should know to come see you
you're the barnes noble on 5th avenue
tonight right yes today very cool very
cool okay i mean
i imagine when you are a real housewife
the dream is obviously to get your own
show and it's one that very few houses
you know karen hugo from atomic just got
one it's a real honor and i'm curious
one how it feels and two if you've got
any words of wisdom from uh
kim zolciak she did it as well oh yeah
that's right she oh absolutely a long
run too um you know i had a taste of it
because i did porsha's baby special
porsche was having a baby yeah so good
and so i did that so i had a taste of it
but it wasn't like this one yeah this
one involved all of my family um and i
didn't get any advice from advice from
kim
um i would say the biggest thing for me
was just to go into it and just be real
yeah you know over the years i started
the show housewives when i was 30 years
old up until now the cameras don't exist
what you see is just me yeah it is what
it is i believe that yeah and so
that's the same thing i went into this
family show with yeah i couldn't do it
any other way especially because the
show is about the truth yeah the show is
about honesty it's not about perfection
no hello public the show is not about me
being perfect being singing perfect it
is what it is that's probably what the
show could have been called it is what
it is it is what it is i'm just saying
you know because i knew i saw some
people they were like i don't think the
show is showing her in the best light
well
who is if you really put a camera and a
magnifying glass on them yeah but this
is my true journey and there is a lot of
beautiful moments within some of the
craziness no it's really good i love it
i think it's going to be great yeah um
my final question for you is last night
was a really big night on bravo i know
you were on watch shopping live i did
watch but also nicki minaj was on the
real housewives of potomac oh my god and
i want to know what your thoughts on
that were and then i also want to know
you were on you did many a reunion if
you could have had any celebrity who
like love the show come on and do a
reunion who would you have wanted
oh my gosh first of all i didn't even
know that nicki was as big of a super
fan as she is but i think after all of
us seeing her host you know for a fact
she's the president oh the fan club oh
my god she knew so many details that it
was like oh my god my people no i know
we are the real housewives tribe yeah
i'm a part of the fan club as much as
i'm on the show which is kind of crazy
um so she was asking questions that i
knew that had been burning yeah i could
see her at home yelling at the cam at
the tv the michael darby stuff yeah oh
yeah she got very detailed she did i was
really surprised and she wasn't letting
up on anything on anyone and i like how
if she was grilling one person she was
telling the next one can you hush and
let me finish yeah i thought it was fair
i'm gonna get there girl like don't walk
me too fast with my questioning so i
thought she absolutely killed it okay so
for a celebrity host to host the
reunion i mean it has been said that
beyonce i was just like girl you just
read my mind that's what i say beyonce
and solange do watch the housewives and
i want to feel like michelle obama be
watching for sure she would be very good
at reunion like she's very diplomatic i
imagine her asking you something how
dare you sideswiper lied to michelle
obama you know what's so crazy your show
is so big i actually could see it i know
that sounds crazy but like especially
now with nikki like yeah i actually
really could see a world and with which
there's like a panel beyonce salon jim
michelle i could and let me tell you why
because who doesn't want to see the
former first lady
just dive into her guilty
pleasure like we want to know that you
love all of this drama and it's not even
guilty you know i hate when people say
that i'm proud like that i watch
housewives i don't like the word guilty
pleasure because it adds a negative
stigma and i think the show is great let
me take that from you it doesn't have to
be a negative um it doesn't have to be a
negative guilty pleasure is you could be
going through your own [ __ ] do you
persuade yourself yeah please you could
be going through your own [ __ ] alone and
then of course you can see other people
go through theirs that's true what's
wrong with that it's nothing wrong with
that you know i did have another
question for you because on last night's
episode you were going through like a
house search
and i feel as a fan very attached to
your house um the one with the big
columns because it's obviously like this
was this wonderful place for you like
a paradise almost that's where you
brought pj home and it's just where you
were able to start over and you did it
on your own and i think all like the
women watching were like yes get that
house yeah where do what is your current
living situation do you still have that
house i'm glad you feel that way because
so did i i could not give it up i am
keeping it oh yes yeah i'm actually
going to give it to my mom so
yeah we're going to be a family home i i
same freezing you said you know when i
bought that home remember i was picking
the rooms for the babies yep and pilar
ended up in the little girls room that's
crazy i just simply took the name off
the wall so
um you know i i definitely am creating
new memories with my my family but i
definitely want i had to hold on to it
no i'm so lucky
i didn't expect to watch him feel so sad
like i just thought that house was like
a beacon of hope for all of us you'll
still see it you'll still see it if i'm
on tv we'll be filming there um
including in my new home we just that's
very exciting yeah we just closed oh so
you've found a house yes for the blended
fam mm-hmm have you guys ever watched
the movie blended
no okay so my sister jackie she's
pregnant right now it is her favorite
movie and it's about a family that
blends obviously and she says that every
single family who's about to become a
blended family we should watch a movie
it's kid friendly it's really good you
should watch it i'll watch it
congratulations on the book
congratulations on your engagement the
show it's the season of porsha and we're
just so excited that you are here thank
you for stopping by and you guys make
sure to get the book available
everywhere amazon barnes and noble and
if you're in the city tonight she's
going to be at barnes noble tuesday
you guys i want to talk to you guys and
sign some boats so yeah thank you so
much porcha thank you guys we'll see you
tomorrow bye